please welcome my friend
hello
speedman
hello how are you i'm so happy to see
you
happy to see you too i want to start
with congratulations
oh thank you you are
seconds away from having a baby with
your girlfriend
i know any day now so i'm checking my
phone all the time when i'm away and all
that stuff is it true that you have
brought something over from a nearby
friend
oh well yes we had to go pick up we're
doing it at home we're going to try to
do a home birth for this one so we we
had to go pick up the tub from our just
happened to be our neighbor we don't
know these people i just knocked on the
door and this guy just delivered this
tub and now i'm in charge of blowing it
up and getting the water in and all that
stuff so it's kind of a weird experience
i'm not gonna lie when we used to like
prance around all of us we had a core
group of friends who were all connected
so
scott and i were connected and um we
just went on really fun adventures
together
and
we were not
anywhere near parenthood at that point
and to see us now all growns up it's fun
yeah that feels like a long time ago but
it really wasn't that long ago but it
feels like a long time ago to me for
sure i have a picture
here uh-oh there you go there's you and
justin long uh-huh having a good old
time
yeah that's the party guy face right
there for sure and well i think it goes
a little notch higher there you go there
you guys speak
okay here's my theory on this one i used
to ride my bike everywhere like i'd ride
my bike to a party hang out for a little
while then ride my bicycle to another
party and i think that's me deciding to
change into like my party outfit in the
middle of the party so that's what's
going on there i feel like i got it all
out of the system way back when and now
i can just watch netflix at night and do
nothing me too speed men i mean i have
two little girls nine and seven and they
are the love of my life and i too am at
home watching netflix which is a perfect
parlay into the fact that not only
grey's anatomy which we'll get into in a
minute but the show you i mean
everybody loves this show i'm obsessed
with it
how did you come about joining that cast
you're like in every cast i'm freaking
out
uh you know to be honest my girlfriend
was obsessed with that show so i'd watch
it over her shoulder every night and
then during the pandemic i got the offer
to come do it and i thought you know it
was a great role interesting role uh why
not take a shot so there i was on you
and then let's get into grey's anatomy
ellen okay
directly um
and i was wondering what her
conversation with you was like when she
asked you personally to do this
um i just gotten off another show and
she sent me the script and it was you
know to be honest was a very well
written script and i thought it'd be fun
to go do and i really like her and just
decided to take a shot i was naive to
think that would be my only episode but
as soon as that episode aired they
started you know asking me to come back
and it wasn't the right time but this
year they asked me to come back and it
just felt right so i i jumped on and i'm
to be honest i'm having a lot of fun
doing it i'm not surprised alan pompeo's
asking you to personally come step into
this role but my god the fans of this
show with the mcdreamy and the loyalty
and the fastidiousness of who is ever
going to like be with this woman that
must have been like i mean
there's a lot of baggage there with like
people and their opinions
yes there was a lot of opinions i you
know they had warned me that the fans
are quote-unquote very passionate i
didn't really know what that
i didn't really know what it meant until
the the show premiered my girlfriend was
showing me stuff on twitter and it was
all very positive and then i made the
mistake of going over to the instagram
page for grey's anatomy i just decided
to take a peek at the comment section
and that was like you know shelly long
in the shining finding jack nicholson's
writing just it was like 12 000 comments
of uh you know diatribes against me just
all caps no no no they're very
passionate they have their own ideas
about who she wants to be with and
it's a it's a very big cult following
people love it and then you recently
just joined social media for the first
time ever right i did why did you join
well i don't know i mean you know
everybody i worked with was talking to
me about it for years and i've always
been like no it's not the right fit i
can't do it oh god there it is
[Laughter]
i'm not much of a shower i'm more of a
private dancer in that way i don't
really like showing stuff like the idea
of doing selfies just seems crazy to me
and putting them up there i get that
that's what it is but that's just
difficult for me and i don't think
that'll ever change but
you know you know it's good for me to do
it's good to break it wide open so i
don't mind giving it a try but we'll see
how long it lasts i'm not so sure can i
get involved in your social media
presence yes i need some help
[Music]
you